yesterday evening
and appalling crime happened in our city
during which
people died eight people were seriously
injured and
we
feel a feeling of the deep sadness and
deep sympathy with the relatives of the
victims of the injured we hope that the
injured Will Survive and we wish them a
speedy recovery it is a horrific crime
a very cruel crime as we will hear later
in Hamburg
we have experience
many things
somebody running a mock like that is
something that we have not experienced
in the past we see it on television it
happening elsewhere but we never thought
it might happen in our city but now it
has happened it is the worst crime in
the more recent history of our city
foreign
it is due to the very fast and decisive
action of the police force
that we don't have any further
victims deployed the crime happened
around nine o'clock last night in the
district was parcel in a building which
is being used of the
Congregation of the Jehovah's Witnesses
at 2104 the first reports were received
some of them from the building at 2108
four minutes later the forces were on
site at 2109
the osv forces the Special Operations
forces arrived
they are a bitter equipped and operator
in a
foreign
special situations
online they were on site at a 2109 at a
21-11 they entered the building by force
and they interrupted the ACT
and separated the perpetrator and the
victims and we assumed that in doing
that they saved the lives of many people
the perpetrator
LED
to the first floor when the better
forces arrived and then he took his own
life so we are dealing with Aid
fatalities
afterwards
arrived on site obviously it was a
large-scale operation of the police in
Hamburg also of the fire department of
the Emergency Services
we have a a prepared concept for these
kind of events and it was
implemented very professionally and
comprehensively last night we were not
quite sure at the time whether there
might be a second perpetrator that
turned out not to be the case
and very quickly and very
comprehensively the injured were looked
after
all
those that needed
um psychological care
and
relatives the eyewitness the people
involved in this crime one cannot
imagine what people went through that
were immediately involved in this attack
amongst the dead there is also
an unborn child of seven months that was
hit
in the mother's womb and
with that first of all
my sincere thanks to all the forces
foreign
carried out this extremely difficult
operation last night with a great deal
of professionalism there were on site
very quickly
and they did what can be done in these
difficult circumstances and they
restored
safety quickly again
here more regarding the operations
the head of operation last night and the
head of the police force Matia stressed
and then we can also
tell you what we know about the
perpetrator and the background thank you
very much Mr Carter good afternoon
ladies and gentlemen Matias tresp
the head of police
and a head of operations last night
um
we considered it to be the act of
somebody running a marker for which we
have a concept that we use for our
operations
I would um quickly walk you through it
at 2104 in the fire department as well
as in the police headquarters we
received altogether 47
emergency reports that appointed to a
very dramatic events there was talk
about shots being fired in the building
of Jehovah's Witnesses which led to a
large-scale operation carried out by the
police and the fire department at 2104
we did not know
um what we were dealing with
as Senator quota said
with e doesn't
colleague
people from Osa
this is the unit that collects evidence
and they were still here
working very near the crime scene
so these forces arrived at a scene very
quickly and because of their special
training particularly when it comes to
terrorist attacks and people running a
mock they recognized the situation they
realized that they could not possibly
wait and immediately they tried to get
entry into the building it was not that
easy the door was locked
they had to use weapons they shot
through the window that allowed them to
open the door get hold of the door
handle so they gained entry into the
building and before that
before they could enter they kept
hearing shots and
building recognized somebody that could
be the perpetrator somebody who was
fleeing that person fled to the first
floor and the police officers considered
that to be somebody fleeing from them
so they went into the various rooms of
the building and then realized that
there were several people in one room in
a hole there's so some people lying on
the floor and some people running to the
first floor so they pursued him and
realized that the person
running to the first floor was somebody
carrying a weapon
we um
I only knew there was one lifeless male
on the floor with a weapon next to him
and as Senator Carter said earlier we
realized later on that because of the
very quick and decisive action the
visitors to the building entered the
perpetrator could be carried out and uh
they exerted pressure on the perpetrator
this is what we want to do in these
kinds of operations you need to act
decisively and quickly to narrow down
Eddie room to maneuver after perpetrator
in order to try and avoid a further
victims occurring
okay
what do we know about the perpetrator
without
um
taking anything away from the criminal
police
so if you look at the road on the right
hand side he neared the building there
was a a meeting in the hall with about
50 people in the congregation and uh
before the perpetrator went into the
building he encountered a woman in a car
on a parking lot he shot 10 times at the
car the woman managed to escape and
drive away she reported later to the
police and then through the window the
shooter shot into the building it got
into the building through the window
continued to shoot
we found several rounds we will hear
about that later he continued shooting
while entering the building and here I
bring both of those pictures together
and then the first officers arrived on
site and was then separated from the
congregation
around 20 people managed to flee from
the building unharmed that they were
injured
and we assume that the decisive action
saved the lives of many
the situation was then that we didn't
know whether it was a lone gunman
obviously it's a very difficult
situation there's so many things
happening there's a wealth of
information sometimes conflicting
information
initially
we thought we have uh somebody upstairs
with a gun
badly injured so we had to uh double
check
whether it was the gunman looking at a
mounting evidence
we had Witnesses with
um videos
taken from
a nearby petrol station and that
led us to believe there might be two
people involved
we knew that the building was Secure
there were no further perpetrators in
the building but then the question was
is there somebody outside is there
somebody in the city that was involved
in the crime so that was a challenge for
the hours that followed and we um
foreign
Witnesses buildings in Hamburg we
checked whether they were any further
Gatherings had that been the case he
would have gone straight away on site
but there were no further Gatherings at
the time
got further information we managed to
look at all the video footage and the
witnesses that had not been injured
could then be
um
interviewed by the police and that they
gave us
the certainty that there was only one
perpetrator involved
many challenges particularly when
there's such a wealth of information
there was a video of one of the
witnesses very impressive we managed to
look at that very early on and
um looking at that video people would
have thought that there are two people
trying to get into the building when we
continued looking at the video we
realized it was the second person it was
a shadow and that shows you the kind of
a difficulties when under um
imminent time pressure you need to act
because obviously we wanted to make sure
that we provided help as quickly as
possible
all in all
as far as the police is concerned the
first phase
went
according to plan
in these tragic circumstances I.E
um the officers got into the building
very quickly managed to get people out
of the building and gave the emergency
service is the possibility to enter very
quickly to provide medical Aid which is
particularly important when we're
dealing with these kind of injuries
this would be
my report to you today
is
mentioned
we have eight injured four of them
seriously injured and amongst the police
force there are a number of colleagues
that also need a looking after now and
amongst the police and the fire
department and we have colleagues
affected
they received a phone call from somebody
who could no longer
um tell them what was going on because
the person was shot and obviously that
is very tragic it leaves its mark on the
people dealing with it
thank you very much so that is my report
to you today
my name is
I am the head of the public prosecutor's
office here in Hamburg I would like to
give you some information
somewhere shaft
regarding last night from our point of
view
I would also
like to convey my condolences our
thoughts are with the the Dead the
injured their friends and their families
last night representatives of the
prosecutor's office were on site very
quickly to people from the homicide
Squad were inside very quickly it was a
dynamic situation we couldn't rule out a
terrorist background so we are very
early on made contact with the federal
prosecutor in Carlton
because we didn't know whether there
might be a second or a third perpetrator
at a half past midnight
we gave the order to get into the
apartment of the perpetrator various
things were found 15
um magazines loaded and another four
um packets of ammunition
other evidence was a secured laptops
smartphones obviously we are uh
looking at these at the moment
as far as we know now there is no second
perpetrator so
there is also no terrorist background
and because of that the general public
process is cute for Germany does not be
involved the perpetrator is not known
to the authorities
he has not committed any offenses in the
past the only thing we know is that he
reported crimes because of a potential
of Fraud and one of these reports is
being followed up at the moment this is
the report from the public prosecutor's
office
good afternoon ladies and gentlemen
I would like to start by giving you some
details regarding the fatalities
four men and two women at the ages of 33
to 60 years and a female fetus of seven
months
all the fatalities are German citizens
can you hear me better now
foreign
women the age is 33 to 60 years and a
female fetus of nine sorry of seven
months all German citizens and they died
because of
injuries through shots
another one from the Ukraine all of them
suffered
serious injuries multiple shots
[Music]
35 year old perpetrator Philip F
committed to the crime we heard that no
offenses had been committed by him in
the past Eve was found dead in
is a former member of this Congregation
of the Jehovah Witnesses
around 18 months ago he left the
congregation but there were ill feelings
since 2014 he'd been working in Hamburg
he was not married he had a a license as
a a sports shooter
the weapon was a weapon that was
found next to the perpetrator that there
were a nine empty magazines found
another 20 magazines in his backpack and
another two um
he was holding another 15 full magazines
were found in another 200 piece of
ammunition
each magazine has a up to 15 shots we
found a various electronic devices and
written documentation based on the
current Witnesses based on the magazines
found and the available
pictures available we assumed that he
was alone gunman at the moment we do not
have any clear idea regarding his
motivation
it currently there are no details
regarding potentially political
motivation behind the crime ladies and
gentlemen
question that is always asked is how do
people get hold of weapons and so please
let me talk about this very briefly
the license obviously uh checks are
being carried out
um one checks police records the one um
approaches the Constitutional courts and
to all of these checks have been carried
out
in addition
um the relevant weapons Authority
received an anonymous report in January
2023 a letter from an unknown person
should be checked also whether he should
have a license
he personally said Philip
fondue might be suffering from a mental
illness without that being medically
diagnosed
because Philip F does not want to be
looked after by physicians
he was said to be enraged against
religious people particularly Jehovah's
Witnesses and also his former employer
because the letter was Anonymous
officers carried out a further
investigations because they could not go
to the person who wrote The Letter
directly so they looked at the sources
available and they could not find any
information because
um no offenses had been committed on the
7th of February Phillips
two officers went to his flat
there are an anonymous reports
usually
by way of teen operation
officers go and check the residence
this check was unannounced they wanted
to go and see Philip F without having
announced the visit beforehand
they
encountered him at home he was
cooperative he was happy to give
information it was an open discussion
they looked where the weapon was being
kept it was in a safe
and the officers considered
um
sticking to the rules apart from some
ammunition being on top of the safe but
other than that there were no other
violation of the rules
and the officers did not clean any
information regarding any mental
illnesses they talk about various things
about
um the floods about things in the flood
and
horses
because of the
um small violation
he got a warning he apologized for it
and um he put that
straight away into the safe so the
officers did not
have any further options to do anything
else
in this respect
locations
they could not
take the weapon away nor could they ask
for
um a mental assessment because there was
no Legal Foundation
because there was only one Anonymous
letter
um and the officers could not do
anything else apart from what they did
Philip F was not known to the police was
not registered
no further reports had been received
um
they had been various
checks regarding his personal details
a weapon and to buy a munition so he
was in possession of this weapon legally
and according to what we know this is
the weapon that was used to commit the
crime
the colleagues in the weapons Authority
checked up
on
what they knew
and looking at what is now happening
um we need to have a critical look at
procedures and we need to
um
check whether an illegal means can be
adjusted and whether we can optimize the
current rules thank you very much
I assume there are questions we have a
colleague with the microphone
give us your name and who you're working
for and who you would like to ask the
question
I think is the first one
I have one question Mr Maya regarding um
to what you said you said various checks
had been carried out
do you have any insights
he studied in Munich where there any
reports about misuse of drugs
Bavaria
we did not have any of these insights
and
um we need to double check whether
um we should have gained these kind of
insights that will be part and parcel of
um checking the rules afterwards I would
like to know how I got the license was
it uh um because he was a sports shooter
and do we know how many shots were fired
you said that he shot 10 times at the
car in the parking lot before he entered
the building
all together
um he fired nine magazines with 50 shots
and
he um got the license as a sports
shooter
could you please let us know about the
victims how old they were but could you
please um list it individually
let me find
the right information for you
we have
a woman
23 years of age
a man
33 years of age a man
66 years of age a man
sorry a woman
33 years of age
amen
32 years of age a woman
27 years of age
a woman
23 years of age
and
another woman 33 years of age the
some two of the fatalities are 40 years
old a 168 uh one um born in 63 one born
in 82 one born in 89.
Mr farmer
I would like to ask you regarding the
support unit he said it was lucky that
they were nearby and so
um were they about to
um finish their work for the day and
then
um looking at uh Jehovah's Witnesses
um
do we need to take another look when it
comes to people leaving Jehovah's
Witnesses okay um
um I can answer your first question I
cannot really comment on the second uh
the uh support unit
consists of
um a special unit taking evidence for
the police force Hamburg and in 2020
after the events of the terror attack in
Vienna
where um
the measures there led to a very quick
success against somebody run running a
mock we looked at the possibility of
putting something like that together for
Hamburg
so we have the opportunity to send this
unit in before then the irregular police
officers turn up on site
when it comes to these kind of
operations we carried out a pilot in
November 2020 and then very quickly
after six months we realized that this
is a very good concept and now to your
question
um
even obviously we cannot
have them cover 24 7.
they are
doing a shift at the moment we have 10
officers and a day a cover Monday to
Thursday
and they
um operate with two vehicles so if there
are any kind of situations that requires
specialized specialist forces they then
arrive very quickly and uh
the officers were about to finish work
for the day that they realized that
there were shots being fired nearby and
and they immediately then went to the
scene
I can add to that
it is a measure that we implemented only
a little while ago in
um Hamburg and we had a pilot and um
obviously these officers also need to
sleep at some point so it was a sheer
coincidence
they were nearby
um
otherwise they would need at least 30
minutes to get on site but because they
were nearby it only took them three
minutes to be
um on the scene and they could react
very quickly and very decisively all the
other things are also irrelevant but
obviously a dessert especially also need
to sleep at some point and obviously our
regular officers are also well equipped
but they are not uh
trained to the same degree
um as these specialist units and I think
um that was fortunate in these
circumstances
as a lady have you with a question
uh Mr quarter sorry
um first of all
um can we say anything
regarding
um
Jehovah's Witnesses and to people
leaving Universe Witnesses from a point
of view of State protection
um we cannot share any insights at this
stage
I was just wondering
why that he targeted the Jehovah's
Witnesses was there some sort of a
disagreement
question with an englishness being
translated into German at the moment
at the moment we can not give you any
details this is part of the current
investigation
Mr battle
two questions
foreign
carried out by the weapons authorities
are those sufficient and um do you know
anything regarding relationship between
victims and perpetrators
well looking at this crime uh the um
checks of the weapons Department
cannot be sufficient but that was the
legal basis there was nothing else in
place and so we need to
carry out checks we do uh carry out
checks unannounced and they do anything
they can as I said we are revisiting
this we need to look at what is possible
from a legal point of view and obviously
after such a crime obviously one
revisits
the situation
they also need to look at what have we
heard regarding Jehovah's Witnesses is
there anything is there anything on file
and obviously we will have to have a
closer look at that but it's impossible
after just a few hours after the event
the question
offer a licenses well obviously we've
been looking at that for quite some time
the legislator has been looking at it
for quite some time
when it comes to checking applicants
checking for
conspicuities for mental
um problems
um draft glitches legislation is being
prepared
and
um
medical certificates forzid these are
gazettes should be provided that's part
of the draft legislation but it is
currently still being debated and so
it's still draft legislation and if
there are data in Bavaria we should be
able to share these
49a and offer the data Protection Law
needs to be Revisited the police data
protection act and uh
have some limitations obviously you have
things on the wish list but the question
is can they be implemented
we have Mr Xander
and another colleague Christopher
lindick
any of the victims relatives of the
perpetrator and had he been
asked to leave the congregation the
victims are not related to the
perpetrator and
um
had he
been excluded from the congregation
there are conflicting news some say he
was excluded some others that he left on
his own accord well
um I counted the magazines nine empty
another 20
um
and 15 at home looking at the his
ammunition
um did the people checking up on him did
they realize that he has had so much
ammunition was that one of the aspects
where people were saying well maybe
there's a problem here
well that that is the question that we
need to look at the the check carried
out
um led to the uh
the fact that we assume that at the time
of the check
um he had a less ammunition
he had the one weapon but I can't tell
you for sure because we need to have a
closer look at the report says that
there where no issues at the time
the shaft so the question is did he get
hold of a more ammunition later and what
um does that mean but that is part of
our further investigations
another question here
Mr Schmidt
officers
who are they
the officers that
carried out the check at his home and
can they really again inside the into
any mental problems they are offers us
that a work for the weapons
um office they have a relevant
experience and they have experience also
with the anonymous reports but
um whether they have any special
training
foreign
the letter said
he might have a mental illness so that
the officers are not trained to look for
mental illnesses but when they were
uncited they didn't get any indications
to carry out an investigation you need
further evidence and that was not
available
the questions in the room here
as far as I know in paragraph six of the
weapons law the uh check of a mental
state must be carried out if there are
reports can you let us know why the
officers did not see any reason
particularly
um if they found a bullet on top of the
safe
you need facts
an anonymous letter which can be based
on any kind of intention it does happen
that
um
people
want to inflict a check on somebody
um
legal facts requires more than just one
Anonymous letter
and uh
he was allowed to have a weapon so he
was allowed to have
um cartridges
the question was whether um
the weapon was kept
as required the weapon was kept in a
safe and only one cartridge was on top
of the safe so that is not uh um a
reason
um to follow up it just led to a warning
and I described his reaction he
apologized straight away and put the
cartridge into the safe
sorry Channel 4 News uh you say
telephone news
knowing what you know now do you wish
you'd investigated it in a different way
do you have any regrets
did you understand the question
um
to repeat it the officers
um followed this
um Anonymous report
using the legal means available to them
they went there and
checked him out and they said we do not
have a legal basis in order to request a
psychological assessment
that would then lead to perhaps um
withdrawal
now we need to look into what can be
done better whether the legal basis it
can be changed must be changed it is a
federal law it's being reviewed at the
moment or whether we say there needs to
be a better exchange of information but
the bottom line is an anonymous letter
where somebody is worried that there
might be a mental problem that on its
own
is not a basis on which you can become
active
um that
would also mean that any Anonymous
letter would then trigger
um things that might not be caught from
popular Poland such one
I have a question so how a concrete
where these Anonymous reports
um
um is that um he was enraged against
Jehovah's Witnesses was he a member of
the congregation in islstaddorf and
where there
any indications that there was a
particular danger or was this
indication not quite as concrete well
according to what we know there is a
relationship he was part of the
congregation whether he left on his own
accord or whether he was excluded you
need to check up on that they are
conflicting reports on this but we do
not have any information from the
congregation
from a member of the congregation that
they
threatened by Philip f
M at least up to now we have not gained
any such information
I speak 44 000 Jehovah's Witnesses here
in Altona in Hamburg
ER and
for the congregation affected as you can
imagine we are horrified and our prayers
our sympathy is with the victims
together with your officers we work
together through the night thank you
very much for your professional support
we would also like to thank you very
much for
um your decisive actions which prevented
worse from happening
perhaps a small correction regarding the
number and the congregation it was an
official Gathering
36 people were present according to what
we know
online
the 36 were present uh
traumatized as you can imagine
work together with the Emergency
Services of the fire department and
workers from the city of Hamburg in
order to provide care for
the victims for the relatives
and we will continue to provide further
pastoral care
according to what we know
the
foreign
[Music]
he left the congregation on his own
accord
s
Martin Fisher DPA
you mentioned
um reports against
um Philip f
um do they give any indication regarding
his mental state regarding any
connection to the offense committed
and are there any
um other links to his home state Bavaria
there are
um police reports foreign
[Music]
dangerous content but obviously we will
have a much closer look at that now the
former
sorry I can't comment on that I could
not hear the question from the rim and
the report
was against a company in Bavaria it was
filed with the public prosecution in
Munich on and was then referred to
Hamburg
we are checking all of this as part of
the investigation two questions
regarding last night do you have any
insights as to how the perpetrator got
from Altona from his apartment uh to the
scene of the crime because you cannot
really get there on foot
make your own
it's 12 o'clock we've been listening to
a police news conference in Hamburg it's
about a shooting at a Jehovah's Witness
building where four men were shot dead
and two women one of those women who was
killed was pregnant so the dead also
includes an unborn child of seven months
four men two women and an unborn child
killed in this attack believed to be by
a lone gunman who fled the first floor
before taking his own life
well let's bring in our Europe
correspondent Siobhan Robbins who is in
Hamburg for us and was in the room at
that press conference what did we learn
very detailed but also very disturbing
news conference there by the authorities
here in Hamburg as you said they
confirmed that eight people including
the gunman died in that shooting last
night four of the men two women and a
seven month old unborn child now they
have named the shooter as a person
called Philip F he was known to the
Jehovah's Witnesses at the moment they
say they still don't know what the
motive behind this attack was though and
that is a line of inquiry that they are
currently pursuing now they've told us
more information about the police
response a response which the
authorities say saved lives there were
around 50 people inside that building
when the gunman arrived apparently shot
at a woman in a car before entering the
building through a win through a window
shooting
continuously as he entered that building
now the police first arrived on the
scene at a 908 the special unit arrived
around a minute later and they were
inside that building by 9 11 last night
so really just minutes after they
received calls saying that something was
happening that shots had been heard
we're told that a a hundred rounds were
fired by the gunman inside that building
and that the police managed to isolate
him and that he took his own life now
they have since the shooting been to his
apartment and searched his apartment
where they found ammunition there they
say that he was a sports shooter and did
have
um did have a license for a half
automatic weapon which is how it's been
translated but still a huge amount of
Investigation to be done here
particularly as I said trying to confirm
why why did this happen what was the
motivation behind this attack
it does feel like the motive still very
much unknown this is a man without a
terrorist background not known to the
authorities did we get much of a sense
about who the shooter was or do you
think this is just something that they
are really just starting to look at now
so the what we were told about this man
Philip F was that he was known to the
Jehovah's Witnesses that he didn't have
any police criminal record but the
police had said that they'd received
some sort of anonymous letter
um which had made them visit him and the
letter had mentioned concerns
um about his gun ownership and also
about his uh potential mental health
State they said that they did visit him
but they saw
um that he was very cooperative and that
there were no immediate concerns raised
about his mental health situation at
that point and because of that there
wasn't anything else that they could do
going forward now apart from that it
seems that he hadn't been on their radar
at all they consistently underlined that
he didn't have a criminal background so
that will be another line that they will
be investigating now